moi c'est un truc qui m'a vexé c'est
papa pour aussi parce que j'avais des
fonds du matin rapport à ce qui s'est
passé avec m'a dit ça ça m'a énormément
quand on connaît son parcours je
trouvais ça alors on va et cavaliers on
va rappeler en trek havaïanas qu'à moi
ouais c'est ça oui
écoute l'améliorant qu'en fait non là là
où elle fait fausse route c'est alors
après que qu'elle mérite ça il ya aucun
problème
moi je pense que juste là où elle a fait
une erreur c'est quand elle parle de top
ouais c'est ça c'est quoi le top-10
freyming non le top-10 streaming j'y
suis pas mais par contre je vends par
contre le top-10 physique qui se vide
plus important c'est ça le top 10 de
rentrer aujourd'hui j'y suis depuis 17
ans donc en fait cia est en fait il faut
il ya juste deux générations la qui
s'opposent en fait entre guillemets
c'est à une autorisation de d'un public
d'une génération web qui a commencé en
2003 et un public qui est là depuis
trois ans qui est très stream
le problème d'un du public streaming
c'est que c'est aussi beaucoup de
touristes c'est des gens qu'ils
n'achètent pas forcément ils ont la
bosse chez ricard c'est le buzz du
moment donc elle a beaucoup de gens qui
l'écoutent ça c'est fait certitude elle
cartonne c'est une certitude mais quand
on vend 500 mille albums dont les trois
quarts sont en streaming
on peut pas garantir que c'est 400
milles sur edel qui vont voter d'acteurs
mois quand j'en ai trois cent mille j'en
ai trois cent mille qui sont d'une autre
comme des brutes en fait c'est pas une
question de qui cartonne le plus c'est
le public le plus motivé le clou mais
rien n'est acquis merrill caresser ou
pas du tout non parce que manger des
raisons justifiant non après 17 ans de
chiffres que je fais ou pas